one second all
right it shows that we are live give it
we'll give it a second for everything to
kick in make sure everything's good but
David Stig Hansen thank you so much for
linking up with me
today it's my
honor my pleasure you have been to the
wrist shot structure two different times
what was the year you first went there
and what was the year that you last went
there I went both times in the same year
you okay so what what year was that 2022
2022 so right on uh coid was hot and uh
I okay let me go back can I go back a
little bit I don't want you to pull up
the picture of me sitting in the mouth
of um Ketel quad um that's uh when I was
two I'm not going back that far but I
was in Taiwan for 25 years you know I
just posted the military picture happy
Veterans Day to all the veterans out
there Veterans Day to everybody I always
say uh when someone says thank you for
your service I now say thank you for
your tax
I got that line from a buddy I served
with because when we were in Iraq we had
literally steak and lobster tail every
Sunday people like their minds are blown
uh when they hear that and besides the
education it's like yeah so thank you
for your tax dollar yes and by the way
they spent a lot of money I did have a
TS clearance and I had they taught me
Chinese so they spent a lot of money on
me and I was in there for them uh how
many languages do I speak I speak
Spanish and Taiwan y sorry I speak
Spanish in Mandarin uh Chinese Mandarin
and uh I lived in Taiwan so I never
learned Taiwanese there's a difference
but uh yeah it was um the military gave
me that and I went to Taiwan to uh
continue learning Chinese so coid
started again by the way let me just try
this I hate this I wrote a book called
yeah um about the SARS outbreak in
Taiwan during the First Co gave is it oh
there it is is okay well if you're going
to show it you know it's it's under a
pseudonym it's under GS Ferrari and uh
that's a good book it's not just me uh I
I did a bunch of stupid stuff did you
happen to open it it's good toilet
reading put it by the toilet well hold
on let's Circle back to this book
because I I you know with the title of
this thumbnail or you know with this
this live stream people want to know
that you're the guy that went and real
quick before we proceed this gives some
love to Josh zson of world alternative
media who went there as well in 2018 he
made it before me he made it first right
and don't forget archaic lens was there
the same day yeah Graham um I'm trying
to remember his last name yeah he
wouldn't tell he doesn't he doesn't he
likes to be quiet um I think and uh
little he doesn't want your attention
and he was still promising something and
we're still waiting for that right uh
let me still kind of answer the question
so in Taiwan you had the 2018 video
Herodotus the castle and wow that blew
my mind now now as I've told you I've
been looking I've been a Google earther
since 2008 really when I finally got the
setup where I can okay let me let me
check this out saw the eye of Africa
said what the f typed in uh it looked
like an eye of Africa I call the eye of
Africa you call the eye of the Sahara
and that's probably a better term and
then we talked about it goes by both so
then of course I got stuck in Taiwan and
coid happened and I lost my job I was
totally destitute my brother he was 46
passed away he had a heart attack so
I've told you many times I'm overweight
I could die tomorrow I want this info
out there that's why I've been totally
transparent and can I give a shout out
to my channel I need 10,000 subscribers
at Stig YouTube I have it in the
description right down below so to
everyone's aware we are doing we are
streaming simultaneously right now on
YouTube and Rumble and Midway through
this live stream we're going to go over
to rumble and share the the most
interesting things you have photos to
share you've literally been to the
center of the rot structure but in the
description down below well I was gonna
say in the description down below I have
a link to your channel so everybody take
a second to just open up a separate Tab
and hit the Subscribe button on David
Sig Hansen you won't forget that love
Yeah and thank you for that and you know
what it's been five years since that
2018 video so I've manifested that from
then until now I'm manifesting my my my
my life in on Veterans Day too so uh
okay I I was GNA joke and say no you
just want me on so I'll stop living
vicariously in your Shadow everywhere
you turn there's that damn Stig it's
like I was at CAC raising my hand you
know I gotta work it I gotta work it and
um let's hope that this you've inspired
me brother you went to the rot I have
not been there and you've been there
twice so uh it's surreal the way it's
like okay so you come across the video
and the the 2018 video that you're
referring to to anyone listening is the
one where I made it's the one that went
most viral uh where it's like lost
ancient map has Atlantis at the eye of
the Sahara and it was my third video at
that time and it was kind of like the
icing on the cake where it's like this
is x marks the spot like you have a a
map from Herodotus from 20 you know 430
BC that lists atlantes in the same
geographical location of the rot
structure it's like now blew my mind
blew my mind and people will say just to
be fair they'll say well Herodotus
Herodotus however you say his name it's
tomato tomato uh never made a map and
it's so I can't substantiate that he
ever had but when you know fast forward
a few years later and I come across that
map from ponus Maya the Romans very
first geographer and and the Romans
renowned for documenting everything and
I'll bring up pictures here in a minute
but to those who have saw my video uh
from last December it's like it
literally lists you know atlante which
is uh Latin for Atlas in the same
geographical location of the rot and
it's not referring to the mountains
um people told me that that's plural for
mountains or plural for the plural form
um and but where's there nobody gives me
evidence there's a lot of trolls out
there that say a lot of things and you
you can't so I like to check it for
myself by the way let me finish Taiwan I
was a university lecturer I have a
master's in business and uh I would
recommend nobody go to school I hate
education now but um if you want to be a
university lecturer in Taiwan you got to
have a master's and um my point is is
that I've done a lot of presentations
and one thing is that those students
were smart and if I BS them they would
call me out on it and I never wanted to
be wrong so I wanted to have and then
when I shifted into doing the YouTube
and the Rashad I was the same way I
wanted to have the correct information
and uh I've been wrong A lot of times
but you were gonna ask me a question uh
about what was your question let's go
right into it you've been to the rot
structure twice do you think that it
could be
Atlantis I for a short time was off team
rot for a short time after the first
trip but now no way it's 100% was
Atlantis okay and I I'm about to show
you why and how you know was I mean well
there okay so I think one of the first
things were the parallel canals okay a
lot of the stuff is around it and when
people and I say the trolls then they're
so spiteful and so hard you know there's
nothing there you know they don't know
what they're talking about they haven't
looked um I'd like to show you a couple
things right now really quick with the
desktop share a couple of teasers
because the big stuff I want to wait
until after we get through you had a lot
of other questions um sure but diing
that up while you're bringing that up
I'll just run people by the details real
quick here is that the lost city of
Atlantis was said to be made up of a
number of consequential details that
match the Rashad structure first of all
it was said to be made up of concentric
Circle spec specifically three of water
and two of land which matches the rot it
was said to have an opening to the Sea
at the South which matches the rot it
was said to be made up of red black and
white color Stones which is another
stunning similarity in that entire
region around the rot it was said to
have mountains to the north with a river
coming from the mountains and it just so
happens that there's mountains in
Northern Africa just north of the rot
structure in the modern day country of
Morocco called the Atlas Mountains and
what's specific and so important about
the name Atlas is that was said to be
the name of the very first king of
Atlantis so another interesting
similarity or coincidence i' say is that
the very first known king of morania
which is of course the country that the
rot is located in was also named Atlas
so like what are the odds of all of that
but not only that oh let me add you to
the stage here okay not only that um it
was said to have an abundance of
elephants which of course were known to
have been in the western Sahara it was
also said to have an abundance of gold
and the there's massive gold depit
deposits in that entire region um going
back to the mountains I just remembered
that Tam ret River flowed literally from
the Atlas Mountains through the WR shter
just north of it out into the Atlantic
can you see that that's it right there I
sure can I sure yep that's it right
there that's the line where the ancient
Tam reset rivers to have been now you
can see that the I I'm sorry that's so
small let's just go back to the big map
but the the Tam I'm gonna bring up mine
too it came from the this area there was
Lake mcreb it had other well you've been
talking about the trans what oceans I
don't really go it's a little it's a
little hard for me to get into it too
much uh we do disagree on a lot of stuff
uh but I want to show you things that
just can't deny there was ancient
technology in this place real quick can
you see my screen right now is it
showing my slides see I'm seeing your
screen yeah and in fact my screen I'm
not sure if you can see it on if the
audience can see it and by the way I
should probably open up the the video on
your channel so I can see the comments
it's kind of important to me so well I
probably shouldn't get distracted yeah
hold on let's do one thing at a time
because we have so much to unack here so
here's comments yep okay oh well I know
that pretty well that was the very first
one where did that picture come from is
a good question right there this one
sorry
yeah um I mean this is on the Wikipedia
um but it flows literally from the atlas
you can see Atlas right up here and it
flows right over the geographical
location of the rot structure and one of
the reasons why that's so important is
that a lot of people say that the rot is
too high above sea level right so it
couldn't possibly be the location and um
the the reality is that a lot of people
aren't looking at the actual translated
words of the rot or excuse me I'm on the
wrong page here give me a second here
I'm all scrambled up let me remove my
stuff here um the reality is that there
was the word for Island had five
different translations the word andess
and besides meaning an actual island or
Peninsula or PR another translation was
land within a continent surrounded by
lakes rivers or streams and the reality
is that the evidence that the water was
in and around the rot structure is there
for all who have eyes to see I've shared
the satellite imagery of it do you have
in fact that me add yours back again so
look at pan out a little bit and show
people those textbook ation of flal
erosion it's there for all who have eyes
to see so scroll in a little bit I'm
sorry I'm trying to get rid of I'm
trying to get rid of all the words and
sorry about that problem and um yeah
give it a yeah pan in a little bit the
island thing I'd like to okay closer one
of the one of the things that the
islands of I mean you can really see it
just went I don't know if a tsunami
could have done that but I can
definitely see what I see
right happened um let me add something
about the island comment you know a lot
of we'll get into it in the rumble part
because it's a little controversial but
some people ignore the fact that it also
says that there were okay at first I
thought they were saying divers Islands
but I was corrected by somebody who was
a little bit better with ancient Greek
or he said no it's diverse and I guess
they dropped the E and so there were
diverse
islands in the Atlantic that we're also
part of at Atlantis so okay if if if
there's a place that's as big as Libya
and Asia combined and then there's these
diverse islands that are scattered in
the sea outside in the open they say
Open Sea I mean come on uh people are
ignoring certain things they are um I I
feel like there are some people on all
let's be real the Internet by and large
thinks that the rot structure is by far
the most likely location however there
are staunch critics and I have been very
open-minded I have said like look it's
possible Atlantis have never existed in
the first place it's possible that if it
did the r shut wasn't it but for anybody
at this point in time to say no it's not
or could not be that is premature and
foolish it's it's it's it's foolish
because one you can't disprove it and
you have to ignore so many unbelievable
similarities now people will say oh well
it's too large what are your thoughts on
the argument that the rot structure far
exceeds the measurements as outl by
Plato what comes to mind when you hear
that argument against it brings to mind
the I just saw that Rand Carlson
interview where he shows the dot in the
middle of the island and I know for a
fact I did the measurements I I don't
know where you got that number 127 back
in the day and I guess he came from uh
visiting Atlantis and I my own do but I
came up with about four and a half times
bigger than
Plato's right and and so what really I
mean there's a there's a picture right
in the middle you I don't want to keep
navigating around but uh there was never
a time somebody could stand on the cliff
well I can show you here um in this map
oh you're gonna got um this this okay
let's just talk about this is a
shoreline right here okay and there's no
way that you could stand here and
Overlook and see the middle it's just
too far away if you standing here you
probably see out and you see these
distant mountains and I and I drove
right here and took a picture with using
panoramic of the whole Rashad structure
you can barely see it's just barely
coming up but some of these ridges are
as high as the shore and let me just say
one more thing about Shores I want to
make a point and I'll show you one
little fun thing that's also a shoreline
okay so this salt right here from the
evaporated water it's getting covered by
this sand right here whatever brought in
waters floods wind whatever brought this
it's covering this this body of water
right here this body of water is 200
feet long so here's my PO main point and
then I don't have to share screen whoops
oh they always change stuff I'm trying
to turn it back North again I want to
make a point is that the Tam and reset
River ran right here now according to
according to that it hooks up over this
this is a big old mining Mountain I have
my opinions about that then it comes
back down and it exits right about here
so of course they had more than just one
I believe I'll talk about that later but
I believe there's a canal that actually
allowed water to come from this area
through here now so my point is is that
the tamet river was here and like you
just said it doesn't matter how high up
it was because the waterers right there
well let me show you how the water got
there so I believe this was a whole sea
right here maybe but let me show you
this okay just right here okay this is
clearly a cut through bedrock and what
is it what do you think that is do you
think it's a Road okay I can show you a
modern day these are all dirt roads with
tires that's an air strip right there
and it's I don't know what the hell they
want to go there for because this is
literally like 400 miles out in the
middle of nowhere why would somebody
want to go it's like it's like a little
bit of a outcrop of a plateau coming out
of the sand but let me go back in and
I'll hold on that is a can that is Canal
yeah all right so show us this canal so
yeah and that Canal is it shows from
here to about up to here you can keep
seeing it you can look and it's pointing
right over where the tamon were set they
were using these canals to serve this
whole area this this also this one right
here I think everybody's probably seen
this it's four kilometers long and it's
it's so and on this side we've got the
Adar plateau and on this side we've got
a completely different colored Plateau
these canals served water to
everywhere okay so and let me just say
real quick to anybody on I'm looking
through the comments on YouTube and some
people say it's a fat that the rot is is
not
Atlantis right you cut off um let me
just say anyone on YouTube that wants to
leave a Super Chat and ask a question or
share your point of view go ahead and do
so let me also say hi to Suzanne baby
girl for the five dollar pal right there
um honestly hold on Stig I can't hear
you I lost you I'm not talking I'm not
talking can you hear me now okay I can
hear you now never mind I was like the
wrong tab it was delayed um someone said
yes Jimmy I shared the facts with you in
2018 I published published what what how
could you possibly prove that the rot is
not Atlantis because what are the best
arguments I'd like to hear it uh and
that's entertain it because this is all
in good fun but the reality is that you
know the arguments made against it are
that is that it's too large and I'm here
to say that hey it's a 12,000 year old
legend that would have been passed down
through numerous languages loss in
Translation is a real thing and I would
argue that the measurements described by
Plato would make it far too small
because the measurements would equate to
approximately like 3.1 miles or
something around there whereas the wrist
shot is exponentially larger but those
measurements of that three miles is like
60 or 70% water because that's talking
that includes the concentric circles of
water and most of that you know that
area was not a place that could be
inhabited because it's on water so the
point here is that if the rot or if
Atlantis was said to be busy all day and
all night with languages you know rich
in trade with people from languages uh
spoken from all over that implies a
major metropolitan area of millions of
people and I'm here to say that the
measurements that have been provided by
Plato would actually make it too small
like it's just a logical fact that when
you have an area that's just so small
especially if people are going to say
that it's the middle of the Atlantic
Ocean where are you gon to put all those
people I don't think it's feasible to
have it out there but um beyond that
loss and translation is a real thing
like even today most people cannot on
the Fly describe
or or articulate the difference between
the Imperial measurements and Metric you
know feet and miles and meters and and
centimeters and all that and vice versa
they they can't do it so when
something's 12,000 years old and would
have gone through numerous languages I
don't think it's the best argument but
but you know what's the other thing they
say okay the rot structure is not a
natural or it's a natural formation so
it can't be Atlantis and those same
people will say oh but it would have
been an island in The Atlantics so it's
like are islands all of a sudden not
natural and so when we consider that
Atlantis was said to be made by The God
posidon Who was the god of um the sea
and earthquakes Mother Nature yeah male
form of Mother Nature in in if you look
at the definition uh described in the
encyclopedias Poseidon was said to be
lord of the Earth or father of the earth
and like you just said is that seems to
me translating for mother nature so of
course it would be natural we've been
building on natural Fe teachers
throughout human uh mankind sorry go
ahead well I was just yeah thank you um
I was just going to add to that and say
you know I learned a lot learning uh
getting my MBA in International
Management I had to take a lot of
culture diversity type of classes which
was really terrible but I and I don't
even believe High context low context
but there's a lot of true things you
don't have to say something in Taiwan
where I lived and to get your point
across in the United States you do and
it's perceived entirely differently and
for Plato to have said oh it was
Poseidon he could have been basically
implying mother nature and you know we
don't really know for a fact also um
Plato did mention that he still had
solon's notes in his possession and he
studied them from when he was a child so
the telephone game there doesn't really
apply I believe he's going from the
notes of
Solon and by the way in those same notes
Plato literally articulates that
although I have uh went to the best of
my ability to describe the city and the
environs to the the best of my ability I
will now Endeavor to describe the rest
of the region or I'm paraphrasing here
the rest of the environs to the best of
my ability what he's trying to say is
that he either can't read or decipher
so's notes or it was left ambiguous he
just doesn't know right like that's one
of the key details here is that he lit
Plato articulates that when he's
describing this lost city he can't he's
going to have to Endeavor to to
speculate on what it was like he writes
it in his own words I have one of the
slides i' have to bring it up Shand is a
dead thing now we don't have shorthand
anymore but he his Solon probably made
some scribbles that that he understood
but nobody else would you've done it
I've done it yeah real quick we have a
super chat uh from aitar or is ater
where he says you would assume some sort
of artifacts and structures would be
there right what do you say to that it's
okay so I want to say that I am going to
talk about how I believe this structure
was created and how I believe this
structure
the Atlantis was destroyed honestly if
it this is something I came up with um a
long time ago but I'll wait until the
rumble to share that artifacts are still
there we see these canals I will show
you two more canals um I don't yeah
we're not sharing the desktop that much
right now I don't need to but um I would
like to show that later um the donut you
were talking with Ian yesterday about
that little circle to the left Ian cross
okay I I mean I went there I call it the
doughnut um it's got
semiat you zoom in on it real quick on
oh sure show people are talking about
right there I can I can show you where I
entered because I had to drive uh the
road is down here and I had to drive
about four miles across just basically
flatland and see how shitty it is the
the problem is with Google Earth is
they're taking away the resolution and
so I can't even see what I'm looking at
I think it's over here the road there it
is does it look like out there okay yeah
okay so um honestly it's pretty flat
there's this area here that's a little
higher and it's you know what I have to
be honest my second trip um I was a
little rushed in this area and I wasn't
able to spend enough time here we
basically just drove in and got over
here and I realized I wasn't going to be
able to get over with the truck so um we
also uh couple other things were going
on and so I decided let's get out of
here but it's I think it's an but it
looks like a sponge cake that collapsed
in the oven right and so I think that
there was there was water that caused
that it was wet and it dried this this
crevice formed like a separation of
something it's it's pretty far apart so
like a cake separated from the side of
the pan type of thing um yeah I I don't
think you could call that a city Ian was
kind of looking at it and thinking it
was like a a city I think it was an
impact I think that's a small crater
and we'll talk about that it sure looks
like it yeah just so you know we got
like 4,000 people on YouTube right now
another 3,000 on Rumble so we got a lot
of people listening so to those who are
just tuned in this is David Sig Hansen
he's been to the wrist shot structure
twice um and let me just ask the
question again for all to hear David do
you think this could be the Lost ancient
capital city of Atlantis I'm back to
Atlantis I I went away I'm back I'm back
and wait till I show you my big reason
why I think it'll blow your mind it's a
it's another I mean points right at it
it literally points right at it it's
like what why would they do that I mean
I got this topographical map right here
and uh I'll show it see the Adar plateau
and I make a lot of reference Adar
actually means little Atlas apparently
now I I don't I don't have the evidence
to this but people have told me a lot of
stuff and I've heard and my sources are
usually from people who live in that
area now do you see what's happening
here this looks like the eye it's the
eye right but the Adar Plateau is much
higher than the Rashad um and that's why
you know come on 45 kmers wide and
you're tell me that's a volcano um this
is a shoreline and now something
happened here yes you made the point I
want to just stop it right there because
you've said 45 kilometers and that's a
volcano like questioning it what's the
you've said that this is far too large
to be actually the volcano and what's
the largest other volcano because this
far exceeds it correct I I Googled it it
was the monacoa or in Hawaii one of
those is the biggest and the measurement
across the Cal I I don't know if you can
call it a Caldera when it's still a
volcano but we're talking about the
opening at the top is like one and a
half miles okay and this 16 miles or or
well 25 miles uh from one side to the
other but the concentric circles are
like 16 miles so in other words because
to anyone listening the this the rot
structure is a legitimate scientific
mystery the consensus is that it's most
likely a collapsed volcanic Dome however
it doesn't look like any other Volcan
volcanic Dome collapse Dome anywhere
else on Earth there's a similarity when
it's like you have one outer ring and a
collapse nature of it but with the
conectate circles you don't see this
anywhere else so when people say oh it's
just a volcano are you sure it's not to
say it wasn't volcanic in nature but it
doesn't look like anything else on Earth
and again like to emphasize your point
it is far larger than any other volcano
anywhere
besides Mars uh I can't I can't get it
bigger I tried to maximize this this is
a a collap this is a volcanic dome right
in there this big bubble right that's
Mount St and that's supposed to be the
same thing no we we can get into that I
I tell you but let me say a couple
things about um okay you were talking
about thermal activity under here I do
question that now there's definitely
water under this under here so I didn't
see those so-called from visiting
Atlantis those two Wells and in the
middle I was looking for those but let
me just talk about the Adar Plateau a
little more this is okay they say it's
sandstone and they but when I drove up
the road you can see it I there's a lot
of videos of this my my channel but
you're driving up and by the way look
how straight that line is but you're
driving up from a tar you can fly into a
tar you don't have to go to the Capitol
noot and you can fly in there from
Paris uh no I I did it the hard way um
but then getting trucks here is more of
a challenge wait wait let meish one
driving up so you go over here you drive
up and while I'm driving up I guess
you're going right between these
mountains here you're seeing exactly
what this content is and it's literally
it looks like slate but it's apparently
sand I don't know for sure what it is
but it's 2,000 feet thick now you're
telling me that a volcano just bursted
through there made a big bubble didn't
pop or maybe it popped deflated and and
then and inflated million millions of
times and caused these rings and it did
that and and where's all the content
this is look at this chart right here
sorry I did that the yellow is the
yellow is 1327 and the Topia draw is up
here where it turns white 2277 feet so
we're talking about a almost a thousand
feet difference where did all that
content go volcanoes leave a Caldera
this is not a Caldera this is actually I
mean you could argue it is but but
Caldera has a rim and this isn't really
a rim at all okay uh you wanted to ask a
question I was just going to ask where
did you fly in and you drove there
yourself so I was T tell us what it
takes to get to the rot structure
because a lot of people ask me why
haven't you gone there I'm like it's
it's no little journey like that's one I
could be dangerous but tell us about
your experience you flew from where to
where and drove how long
did okay so first how much did it cost I
was okay so my brother passed away in
2021 sorry in 2021 and believe it or not
I think he called My Grandmother home a
month later I'm not really religious but
I'm I'm not gonna say that it sounds
stupid to say but I'm spiritual but
anyways the point is is that it really
meant something to me when she passed
away third I didn't even get to see her
because of coid the caregivers uh I
don't want to get into that but uh I got
an inheritance and the first thing I
said is I'm going so um I tried to I
Okay so it took like 20 Christmas time
we're talking 2021 December finally got
the money to buy the ticket and right I
was I was down at Triple A and there was
a travel agent in there so I started to
talk to that guy and he started to book
it and it was going to cost like 1,500
bucks it was January it wasn't even the
new year yet January 1 I was going for
but um then a new outbreak of coid
happened and all flights were blocked
and I was like damn it and about a few
days pass I said how am I going to get
there so I actually uh got online and
booked it myself for a thousand bucks
LAX to a knock shot KN shot is right
here um it didn't land first we uh we
landed first one time in Guinea in conic
Cree so that's where the airplane landed
I never even got off the plane cleaners
came on but damn it kukree or uh Guinea
it's on my list of countries I've been
to 33 now by the way right on so you
know didn't get off the plane I was
arguing with a guy on the plane it
doesn't count but you know what it
counts uh anyway so then it flew to
knock shot now I got really lucky when I
arrived I did meet a a very friendly
fellow at the airport and some other
fellows that were definitely uh more
interested in getting some money out of
my pocket and and let's be honest I
didn't even have their money I can't
even pronounce it I just wrote it down
and relearned it and I can't remember
the name of the money in uh their
denomination in KN shot but but uh yeah
noshad is a hold on people are saying
asking if you're a 33 degree Mason
people in the comments are wondering you
said 33 and now they're all sketched out
clarify you're not a Mason 33 countries
I've been to 33 countries I went to
Europe when I was young 1977 and went to
a bunch of European countries I've been
back to London since and Amsterdam or
the Netherlands since and uh what it was
and so then I went to Asia I lived in
Taiwan 25 years there I went to 10
countries Hong Kong count
Hong Kong counts because they stamp my
passport go on I want us I want us to be
provocative and a lot of people in the
comments are blowing us up with lots of
provocative questions and we got a super
chat from a gentleman named pee that
said Atlantis is 100% past the straight
of tribal at the bottom of the Atlantic
Ocean not a Northwest African desert
what are y'all talking about what would
you say to that I say sounds like you're
repeating nonsense okay look there we
are by the way zoom in between and I'm
going there in January I'm going there
you're going back I'm going well I'm
going to Spain because I've never been
there before and I want to go across to
Morocco there's some crazy stuff I don't
want to I I'm talking some crazy but
look at that what the heck are we seeing
there we're seeing all these overlays
does somebody want to hide something so
uh yeah and then you get this that is
weird and uh yeah he's saying that it's
right here in the okay let's talk about
that a little bit I mean so let's talk
about the ancient Shoreline in fact I
was just watching Rand Carlson and he's
claiming that's right here but look at
it it's definitely right there it's
definitely right there yeah go on you
mentioned R Carlson so I think now might
be a good time to carry this
conversation exclusively over to rumble
everyone that's in uh the Youtube uh
look in my description there's a link
that'll take you directly over to uh our
Rumble where we'll continue there
because there's a few things to say um
and I want us to focus down on you know
specific questions um and I want us to
really uh kind of hammer I'll talk about
this too I'm gonna talk about um Rudolph
The Rednosed Reindeer and the magic nose
it's very important so I'll talk about
that on Rumble and there's parallel
canals on both sides of that but anyway
we'll talk about that that's stay
focused there's so much stuff to unpack
here so real quick yeah um let just yeah
so at this time everyone on YouTube
click on the rumble link it's streaming
simultaneously over there and so now it
will'll be exclusively on Rumble and
we're going to go into the more
provocative stuff you mentioned R
Carlson I want to go into more of like
the uh a deep dive on that stuff as well
as you're going to share some
interesting photos from the center of
the rot so let me go ahead and just hit
the end stream on YouTube and everyone
it's in the description uh I'm on Rumble
bright Insight the link will take you
right over there so go ahead and do that
now